家で終末感があるね向きはみんなとのんびりお話はちょっとみんなのセンスを今日聞い
てみようと思いますはいという意で今からツイッターの方で募集をかけますスカイ by
子ですつ余ってますみなさんの先生僕を合わせてくださいこれでいいただこれでは家
呟いてしまった範囲まあこういう感じで僕のスカイプ id を晒してしまいました
これで皆さんが僕に skype
で電話をかけてくるというわけでございますなんかねツイキャスでですねコラボって
いう機能があるんだけどもうなんかで見に来る人が多すぎてもう来た奴の帰宅
もう行きたい思ってる
ん
ブーブー
ちょっと結界もくっつきますね
これ
ブーブーブーブーこんなにかかると思って着信2がほとんど来なくた桜
いやあああもうダメだ to do
ブーブー言っ
やばい油断してたまあそりゃそうだよねちょっと待っていけしっかりとタップし
ましょう
オーディオす設定で言ってるんですよね
待ってろといえば朝と弾んだ
すごいなもうやめてショットナビ2階ですね full spot だぜイエーイ
ちょっと待ってなきゃねを通されてこのホとなくと真っ黒とビーズしてる俺がちょっと
いらねぇいいねぇねぇねみんな
あそこんが動かないよ設定れた目から変えないとパソコンが本当にしない押せないよう
になった
もう一軒落ち着いて月起動してみましょう2調査委託せばみんなの会話できるから
スカイプを起動した瞬間に1か月2茶をなくせるかがポイントです
もし何かあんにゃん地を訪ねたハート型は zl ダイヤルパッドを消して
あのダイヤルパッドも決してない感じないの
まあどうせはどうしてどうして同氏は本当に動かないんだけどなんでも反応しないよう
ドラム応答せない
me
どぉすればいい山ってまずどうすればいい通知音さえ
るってるさえなくせば何とかなると思うんですけどみなさんごめんねちょっとスカイプ
でも絶えなかったみたいな
追客のコラボ客も駄目ですねスカイプでも話せないというのはこれはどうやってみたと
話せばいいのか
なるはっはっはっこれみんなと話でしたーい
走ったいけどほど指導所どぉすればいいんだろうけど俺に出来ることなんてないよ
応答してないもんだよあっいいかさあ設定画面までて太郎のカツンッ手紙に行く前に猛
攻撃を避けてうわーこ設定で通知を止めるとすれば誰かしらと電話ができると思う
これは起動に時間が来たよ
米戦艦140球の楽しいつつだうんっ
どうだ
逃げたんん
ばまだ合う子からもうダメだうん何もできねぇほんとに何も的な
で mac pro でしょ mac pro の最高滑ってねはこれやばいな対策を
取らないとしくった今回の店は先に通知をつ版をなくしておけば良かった本当申し訳
ないもうこういう企画はぞみたいなつってるね一息してからもう一回使ふ起動してみ
ましょう
よし起動します期待した
ていた
本
止まってる
って止まってるぽくねこれあ
java の2057県新しい通知
アカウント変えなきゃいけねぇんだから多分無理だもう
それぞれにすることもできない感じなんでまあまあ
マップ上のせいですよ僕が悪いですよもういいですか僕が俺ですけど
すごいねねもうみんなと話ししたいよ
お話サフって今だ
yeah
ええええ
ふーん
はい今回の使ふ企画 by 編
ています